chantal maignan bonjour bonjour ne sait
car plus vous êtes candidate à
l'élection municipale robert alors vous
n'en n'êtes pas à votre première
candidature pourquoi avoir choisi
chantal maignan à nouveau ce défi de
tenter d'être maire de cette bonne ville
du robert et bien tout simplement parce
qu'il y avait la logique de la
continuité de l'action engagée avec mon
groupe
il faut se rappeler qu'en 2014 nous
avions eu un beau succès avec près de
3500 voix et il apparaissait tout à fait
évident que nous devions revenir devant
nos électeurs à la fois pour les
représenter et pour amplifier le
mouvement qui aujourd'hui se
manifesterait très clairement sur le
robert c'est le désir de changement de
rupture d'une continuité qui dure depuis
18 ans et qui montre évidemment des
signes de lassitude
alors selon vous et votre liste quelle
est la principale priorité
ou si vous préférez les deux dossiers
incontournables qui vous faudra saisir
tout de suite si vous arrivez aux
affaires municipales
robert est bien le dossier prioritaire
qu'il faut enclencher dès 2020
d'ailleurs c'est véritablement
l'installation des transports collectifs
aujourd'hui notre ville souffre de cette
paralysie du manque de transport dans
les quartiers du manque de transport
vers les autres communes et cela affecte
énormément la qualité de vie de la
population robertine les personnes âgées
ne peuvent pas avoir accès aux soins
sinon à payer taxi de places qui sont
excessivement chers les jeunes ne
peuvent pas accepter des stages ou un
travail parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
déplacer
c'est véritablement un handicap majeur à
la fois pour la qualité de vie mais
aussi pour le développement économique
il va le soir que le réseau routier doit
être aussi réaménager complètement
aujourd'hui obsolète
on n'a pas profité du plan de relance de
la région de l'époque pour procéder à
ces travaux important d'ouvragés d'art
de ponceaux de route de consolidation du
réseau routier
aujourd'hui il faudra faire avec la
nouvelle collectivité est allé chercher
l'argent où il se trouve mais il ya des
financements pour ça je suis assez doué
volet dossier et nous allons mettre en
place effectivement une qualité de vie
avec le trafic routier et la deuxième
priorité c'est le développement
économique et la lutte contre la
précarité
nous sommes aujourd'hui au robert une
des villes les plus pauvres de la
martinique
parce que nous avons malheureusement
pour nous une bonne
une couche de personnes âgées
aujourd'hui qui ont des petits revenus
ils sont partis à la retraite et c'est
très difficile et nous avons beaucoup de
jeunes en difficulté de formation là on
va dire que la classe intermédiaire les
jeunes sont partis faire des études sont
partis comme beaucoup de jeunes
martiniquais ne reviennent pas donc nous
devons avoir une politique originale à
la fois de développement économique sur
le territoire notamment sur la question
du nautisme en nba extraordinaire et on
peut faire des choses formidables
et puis en même temps sur la lutte
contre la précarité mais il y a le fser
le fonds social de développement qui est
très solidaire et qui a une ligne
particulière pour la lutte contre la
précarité que nous allons évidemment
mobilisé alors je vous demandais quelle
était quelles seraient les deux dossiers
les deux chants tribaux prioritaire si
vous deveniez mère du robert bon vous
avez déjà un peu commencé à répondre à
d'autres questions à la troisième
question
plus globalement pour pour cette ville
quel est l'enjeu essentiel de ce scrutin
municipal 2020 donc pour pour cette
ville et ses habitants surtout oui les
enjeux sont amants aujourd'hui vitaux
nous sommes à l'orée de deux voies de
garage ou d'une renaissance pour la
ville soit avec l'équipe en place
revient la responsabilité et il ne se
passera rien même si autour du maire
actuel de nouvelles de nouvelles
personnalités arrive parce que
malheureusement notre mère n'est pas
quelqu'un qui a confiance et qui sait
déléguer
il y avait d'ailleurs autour de lui des
élus de qualité j'ai apprécié mes
collègues mais il a béni délégation haut
niveau voire d'agir hors pair il est
coutume de dire le maire et bien c'est
son entourage qui est mauvais mais à
l'usagé en travaillant je me suis aperçu
qu'en réalité c'est la délégation de la
responsabilité qui n'existe pas et
quelle que soit l'équipe tu reviendras
autour de lui ce sera le même problème
aujourd'hui la ville a besoin d'une
nouvelle façon de gérer d'administrer et
de penser la relation janry fois très
proche des gens mais en même temps il
faut pas être non plus dans le chantage
affectif il fois dans le pragmatisme le
respect de la dignité des uns et des
autres content c'est à la population
on ne lui a pas rendu au service c'est
normal on a été élu pour ça et on doit
rien attendre en retour sinon du respect
réciproque et c'est ce que notre équipe
entend installer au robert une toute
dernière question chantal maignan qui
appelle une réponse
assez courte parce que nous arrivons au
temps qui nous est imparti est ce que
vous vous allez chercher à avoir
l'investiture de la république en marche
puisque on se souvient que lors de
l'élection présidentielle vous avez été
soutien du candidat emmanuel macron tout
à fait dans le cadre des élections
municipales ne s'agit pas de la même
logique
aujourd'hui nous venons avec une liste
citoyenne qui va intégrer des personnes
de tout de tout de tous horizons et de
tous partis politiques
nous faisons un grand rassemblement
d'ailleurs le mouvement s'appelle
l'union des forces du robert nous
sympathisons avec le gouvernement en
place mais uniquement pour que nos
dossiers soient bien traités sur le plan
national
merci sont à l'union c'est moi qui vous
remercie